mind your decisions i'm preshtalwalker
in quadrilateral abcd bc
is equal to cd angle bac
is equal to 3x and angle bca is equal to
x
then angle cad is equal to 5x and angle
acd is equal to 3x
the question is to solve for the value
of x
i thank juansi from peru for the
suggestion
i had posted this problem on twitter
requesting people send me their
solutions
i thank everyone who answered i want to
specifically thank
at luis and r romero 2
who provided a detailed solution that
helped me provide the answer in this
video
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
i will present a numerical way to solve
the problem
and then i will give a mathematical
proof
a numerical approach gives us a
practical way to estimate the answer
we can construct a quadrilateral with a
specific value like x is equal to 6
degrees
we then construct a circle centered at c
with the radius equal to bc
we then vary the angle x until we get
bc is equal to cd this happens
at exactly one value and that value will
be
x is equal to 10 degrees this answer may
be good enough for practical purposes
but to be 100 sure let's go over a
mathematical proof
we have this quadrilateral and we will
construct bd
let's take a look at triangle bcd
it will be an isosceles triangle and the
angles opposite the equal sides will be
equal to each other
suppose each angle has a value equal to
y
we then notice that these two angles
both have a value equal to 3x
this means that a b will be parallel to
dc
therefore we must have the angle abd
equal to the angle bdc this means
angle abd is also equal to y
from here we will repeatedly use
altose's law of sines
first consider triangle abd we have that
the sine
of 8x over the sine of y is equal to bd
over a d we then consider this triangle
and we have sine of y over the sine of
4x is equal
to bc over bd we finally consider this
triangle
and we have sine of 5x over the sine of
3x
is equal to cd over ad now we recall
that cd is equal to bc so this ratio is
also equal to bc
over 80. from here
we'll take a look at these first two
equations we'll multiply the first
equation by the second equation we can
cancel out the sine
y terms and we can cancel out the bd
terms
this simplifies to be sine of 8x over
sine of 4x is equal to bc
over ad but notice this is exactly
what the third equation is equal to
therefore
we can set these equations equal to each
other
we end up with the following equation
let's simplify from here we'll use the
sine double
angle formula on sine of 8x
it simplifies to be the following we can
thus cancel out the sine of four
x terms from here we'll simplify this
equation
and we get 2 multiplied by sine of 3x
multiplied by cosine of 4x is equal to
sine of 5x
from here we can simplify the equation
using the product to sum
formula we'll let a equal 3x
and we'll let b be equal to 4x
we substitute these values into the
product to sum formula
and we simplify to sine of 7x
plus sine of negative x is equal to sine
of 5x
sine of negative x will be equal to
negative sine of x
we can then rearrange this equation to
solve for sine of x
then negative sine of 5x is equal
to sine of negative 5x
from here we will use the sum to product
formula
with a equal to 7x and b equal to
negative 5x
substituting into the formula we get 2
multiplied by
sine of x multiplied by cosine of 6x
is equal to sine of x from here we can
cancel out the sine
x terms and we get 2 multiplied by
cosine of 6x is equal to 1.
this means cosine of 6x is equal to 1
over 2.
since we want x to be an angle in a
triangle we want to limit to values of x
between 0 and 180 degrees
therefore we can solve that 6x is equal
to 60 degrees
and therefore x is equal to 10 degrees
and that's the answer
it's an incredible trigonometry problem
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on youtube
see you next episode as we continue to
solve the world's problems
one video at a time
[Music]
you